so datastore is a great way to store and
retrieve massive amounts of data so
therefore it is very scalable but it
would still be faster if the data was
served from memory as we know we want
our application to have a small latency
as possible so whatever we can do to
reduce this to better this is exactly
where memcache comes in handy as the
name suggests memcache is a memory cache
which sits next to your App Engine
instances any data you store here can be
immediately retrieved without having to
read from datastore so when you store
data in data storage you can also store
a copy in memcache that means you can
retrieve it from memcache later and
therefore delivery responds really
really fast this is great since you
don't want your users to wait both
datastore and memcache are shared across
any number of instances of your
application that app engine starts this
means that they can all access the same
data provided that your application
updates memcache when it updates
datastore the difference between
memcache and datastore however is that
memcache is a cache this means that the
App Engine platform can decide to free
memory at any time in which case the
retrieve operation will fail so your
application code needs to be prepared if
this happens and in that case retrieve
the data from datastore let's look at a
summary of memcache memcache is of
course not limited to cache data store
information you can put any data you
want in memcache since the data is
retrieved directly from memory the
latency is very low this helps you build
applications that can scale to extreme
levels but since it's a memory cache it
also means that the memory could be
freed and the data be evicted from the
cache so your code cannot rely on it
always residing in the memcache alright
that's the overview of memcache it's now
time for you to hack again by adding
memcache functionality to the comfor
central app